Bitcoin is introducing a kind of
political agenda and passing it off as a
digital Revolution that's not what it is
Bitcoin is the only asset that is not
subject to other organizations
governments or other individuals who can
then come in and unilaterally confiscate
it if we go to war with China I don't
care whether you're going to move to in
the world they're going to grab your ass
and make you fight for America that's
going to include grabbing all your
Bitcoin there's this idea that like oh
God you know the Cyprus government they
took their people's money and what right
do they have well the right they have is
that they're the government crypto
ultimately should be zero you think that
uh anti-censorship anti-cizorship
private property rights and expression
in the digital realm of free speech
those have zero value
well all right guys super excited I've
got Michael schellenberger here with me
uh Michael you tweeted out and said uh
Hey I want to come on uh and talk about
uh Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies uh with
people uh within the uh industry and I
thought a great place to start would
maybe just be like what is your current
understanding maybe positive or negative
about uh Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
yeah well first thank you for having me
on um I am
um someone that cares a lot about
public policy and that means I care
about
having good conversations and discourse
and and also being able to talk with
people that I might disagree with which
is what I think the case is here
um
and um you know I want to de-personalize
it because I do think I suspect that
you're a Bitcoin investor correct do I
have that right of course
um
you know and so like you know I want to
de-personalize it
um and just take it that kind of a
public policy perspective you know I
think it's worth asking whether I'm a
Bitcoin investor or a cryptocurrency
investor I'm not
um
uh
although my my son and wife bought a
little bit of Bitcoin so
um uh but but such small quantities that
are sort of trivial to even mention
um
but yeah I mean my view is probably
pretty close to Elizabeth Warren
um I am viewed as uh you know people on
the far left think I'm pretty
conservative at this point um I think of
myself as a moderate on a lot of
different issues actually but on crypto
I don't think that there's a purpose to
it
um I don't at this point I don't see any
reason it should be regulated because I
don't think it's
like a real thing
um I think it's basically a pyramid
scheme built on top of a criminal you
know digital Enterprise built on top of
a kind of beautiful digital art project
um
so let's let's unpack a little bit of
this right because I think it's uh
that's my car view okay that great
starting point
um one of the ways that I always uh kind
of start these conversations is like
forget
Bitcoin blockchains crypto kind of the
whole nine yards and if we just think of
like the Legacy Financial system uh my
guess is that we probably uh have some
common understanding and common thoughts
I actually think even the Elizabeth
Warren uh and kind of her perspective a
lot of people arrive at maybe three core
beliefs the first is that uh the average
American citizen is worse off
financially today than they were in the
past from a purchasing power standpoint
so inflation's been eating away at
people's purchasing power why Up For
Debate but definitely they have less and
less purchasing power uh kind of over
time there's proponents of minimal
inflation that would argue hey we need
kind of two percent inflation because
it's uh is able to stimulate economic
activity it's able to stimulate velocity
of money and so a little bit isn't that
bad but I think that's kind of One Core
belief that a lot of people both inside
and outside of the Bitcoin Community
have which is this like loss of
purchasing power and I'll come back to
that in a second the second thing is
um I think that there are a lot of folks
who look at the Legacy Financial system
and they say various players whether
they are oversight organizations whether
they are the major Banks whether they
are individual Market participants they
are doing things that run counter to
um kind of the benefits of the whole the
opportunity isn't evenly distributed and
people aren't able to actually
um you know kind of have a fair shot if
you will in that Financial system and I
think you know Warren Elizabeth Warren's
probably been one of the the biggest
proponents of critiquing uh Wall Street
and the various Banks and things like
that right and then the third thing that
I would say is
um I think most people would uh raise
their hand and say yes I believe in the
U.S Constitution right and kind of all
of the things that uh that encompasses
from uh freedom of speech private
property rights and those things that uh
tend to be
um you know I'll say non-controversial
but I'll caveat it with like I'm sure
someone somewhere has a problem with the
US Constitution but it doesn't sound
like like you and so would you agree
that like those three things are
probably common ground when it comes to
you know before we get into the Bitcoin
conversation
yes okay so the reason why I start there
is I I look at Bitcoin very differently
right uh than most people or or maybe
then maybe publicly uh it appears where
there is a very large portion of the
Bitcoin community that looks at it as a
speculation tool right kind of to your
point is people are saying hey if I buy
this and I close my eyes and I wait for
a period of time the price is going to
go up and uh I'm here to get rich right
and right my wife and son okay
and then and look if I'm really honest I
think that to some degree like that
speculation component is true in all
Financial assets right there's even
people who buy their home and they're
like I need a place to live but also I'm
buying this one because I think it's
going to go up in value right so there's
definitely going to be right there okay
yeah so 100 there's a bunch of people
who I think uh are buying Bitcoins and
don't even understand really what it is
they just think they can get rich quick
right well yeah or you yeah more
generously you think it more generously
you just think it's a valuable asset I
mean if I'm being nicer to um I've
teased them because of course they lost
money
um but um it's more like yeah some
people have used their gearish quick
thing some people
May view it as like a long-term asset to
hold like gold
which I suspect is your view
um but there's other people like me who
just think it's a digital art project
with a crime an easy way to money
launder built on top of it with a
pyramid scheme built on top of that so I
think that you know I appreciate
starting with some core values which I
totally share with you I'm sure you and
I share a lot of core values I think
there's an ideological agenda here too
which is basically
anti-statist and I know this because
um
um someone who have a lot of respect for
uh Balaji
uh sure you might say last name right
Trinity Boston correct
um uh and I as soon as we met we started
arguing about cryptocurrencies
Blasio wasted no time he just gets right
now I mean I'm I'm not a PhD in
libertarianism but I feel like I have a
like a pretty solid Bachelor's in it
um and know some of the ways in which
it's different from Classical liberalism
and from libertarianism but I mean
um or I'm sorry from like randianism but
um you know I mean I think that there's
a kind of a I think there's a sort of
it's not a values difference because I
think we all value Public Safety and and
freedom and democracy
um you know there's still a kind of I
think there's a Libertarian fantasy that
is tied up with seastating that's tied
up with a kind of idea of getting away
from the nation state that I think is
absurd because I think it doesn't deal
with Hobbes it doesn't deal with just
the reality of the human animal and the
ways in which we
um that it's just the strong praying on
the weak unless there is a centralized
uh state to protect the vulnerable
so I mean you know I think there's that
going on but I ultimately just kind of
go I don't think there's I don't think
it's a very important part I don't mean
to be mean about it but I don't think
it's also even very particularly
important except for the fact that you
get the pyramid schemes and the crime
and on the crime stuff I kind of go well
I kind of a part of me agrees with the
classic crypto point which is just that
people use cash they use fiat currency
to borrow your language
um to commit crimes that's true I do
think digital makes it easier to money
launder and then there's the pyramid
schemes so in some ways I go the real
question for Public Policy is just
whether it should be regulated and now
having spent some amount of time looking
at and I wrote two pieces
both of which I think are very accurate
and got at the issue around SPF and FTX
um you know you sort of saw somebody who
was very close to getting regulations
that would have helped him yeah and so I
am skeptical of regulating it in part
because I don't I don't think that what
is called cryptocurrency is the currency
I think there's only National currencies
or what you would call Fiat currencies I
think everything else is sort of
see-steading libertarian [ __ ] with
kind of Mafia criminal money laundering
built on top of it and pyramid schemes
built on top of that and the only real
public policy issue is just to warn
people okay I know that this is going on
there's not much otherwise I think
you're just otherwise you know I don't
think there's so I don't think there's
like a regulatory agenda I just mostly
kind of think it has to be kind of
denounced so that's where I kind of come
out okay so so let's um let's kind of
dig a Little Deeper on this the reason
why I start with kind of the Common
Ground on those you know three beliefs
is that my personal belief and I can't
speak to anybody else but my personal
belief yeah is that Bitcoin specifically
if you take Bitcoin away from all of the
other cryptocurrencies which I would
actually agree with you many of them are
not currencies they are uh Ponzi schemes
and all kinds of crazy nonsense whatever
right we're talking about something that
is uh by almost every single person who
looks at it Bitcoin is decentralized
Right meaning that there is no one
person that controls it there is no one
person uh who can make unilateral
changes it's very different than kind of
these centralized either currencies or
organizations
Bitcoin actually embodies and codifies
the American ideals better than any
technology in the world and I'll give
you kind of two uh uh examples the first
is when I talked about Free Speech uh
and the ability to uh kind of have the
protection of the US Constitution
in the financial system today you do not
have free speech right there are many
court cases that prove that software is
free speech and and all the stuff and so
again there is reasons why people will
argue you shouldn't have the free speech
you shouldn't be able to do what you
want with your money whatever but I
think that Bitcoin ultimately says
although you may be sympathetic to a
government or not anyone in the world is
able to send economic value to anyone
else without asking permission of a
third party now in the United States
actually I would argue we've been pretty
damn good about protecting people's free
speech and allowing them to conduct
economic transactions as long as we
didn't deem them to be financing
terrorists or money laundering or kind
of breaking the rules right for the most
part you or I can go to the ATM we can
get money out we can go and buy stuff we
can swipe our credit card we can send
money to people around the world and
like we kind of go about our day other
people around the world you know in fact
hundreds of millions if not billions of
people can't do that and sometimes
that's because uh their governments are
kind of oppressive sometimes that's
because uh there are companies that are
doing things that you know either take
value from them stop them whatever uh or
it could actually be because their
currency is inflating so quickly if you
look at somewhere like a turkey a
Zimbabwe a Venezuela whatever we're
literally the prices are changing in the
store on an hour to hour basis right so
it just makes it nearly impossible to be
able to express your economic view uh if
literally the price has changed on a
day-to-day basis so I think that's like
one piece of this Bitcoin story is the
ability to take the ideal of free speech
and codify it in a piece of technology
and then hand it to anyone in the world
with an internet connection right the
accessibility of this is a kind of a key
component the second thing is this idea
of private property rights so if I was
to ask you you know what property do you
own you would tell me a list of all the
assets that you kind of have on on what
would be the equivalent of your like
personal balance sheet say hey I've
maybe have a house I've got some stocks
I've got some cash I've got uh you know
whatever other kind of assets you own
but if you actually go and you break
that down the odds of you being able to
defend your personal property is very
very low for example if a bank was to
say to you uh we're not going to give
you your dollars back
you yes do have a legal path you can go
to court you can go and try to fight it
and and do all this stuff but what we've
seen is in many countries around the
world Cyprus back in the 2012 2013 time
frame is kind of the quintessential
example that bitcoiners point to they
basically just said look we're just
gonna tax this because we need and they
were able to take that uh currency that
hard-earned economic value from citizens
without any kind of real Rhyme or Reason
or legal precedent and so if you then
were to go and say well let me look at
my house for example there are people
who lose their homes every single day
and sometimes that is because of actions
of their own sometimes that is actions
of other organizations and sometimes
there's things like eminent domain where
literally pieces of their personal
property are then confiscated by the
government and I don't think that this
is so much a anti-government view which
again there are definitely people in
every Community right there's literally
uh people on both sides of the aisle who
think the government is bad or whatever
but I do think that this is very much an
individual rights story and if there's
one thing that we've seen over time in
this digital era it's that individual
rights are being decreased rather than
increased and sometimes there is a
strong argument for why that's happening
kind of the greater good and kind of all
of those those different points but when
it comes to your ability to have freedom
of speech and express your views without
being inhibited by governments
organizations or other individuals and
then also the ability to own and defend
your own personal property
I would argue that in the digital realm
Bitcoin is the only asset where you
actually have ownership of an asset that
is not subject to other organizations
governments or other individuals who can
then come in and unilaterally confiscate
it without your uh kind of agreement
yeah but but I mean just okay well let's
take there's I think there's I heard two
um arguments there one is
Bitcoin is more secure
than other forms of wealth
um and that's in part because
governments can confiscate it and you
gave the example of Cyprus
now
that Cyprus example is really
interesting I mean I really only dawned
I mean when you start talking about it
now because it sort of goes the story
the story that you sort of tell goes
well you could have your assets taken
just like they did in Cyprus and that
shows that your assets are not really
secure in the bank or in some financial
institution
without ever looking at like well why
did Cyprus do that and Cyprus did that
because of course they wanted to avoid a
financial crisis so avoiding Financial
crises is like
avoiding catastrophe I mean it's like
avoiding a hurricane or avoiding you
know the collapse of what just occurred
in Sri Lanka you know
um so this is what should individuals
but should individuals have their
hard-earned wealth confiscated to pay
for the sins of their government or
their Central Bank
well I think um there's a very um that's
a that's a kind of uh values question
um before you get to it there's a more
interesting I think practical question
which is um I come from a long line of
of pacifists
and my my uh some members of my extended
family and certainly the members of my
family in the past would say wait why
should I have to go and die and fight
and kill in a war that I did not create
why am I responsible
either for going some other country to
fight or having to defend my own country
physically
um I didn't sign up for that and I
actually have a lot of uh
I still have a lot of respect for
pacifists um it's a super courageous
position because the result was often
that you would end up still being sent
to war but not with a gun or you'd have
to or you'd be basically you know
imprisoned or persecuted or tortured or
killed or whatever because of your
position so when I I can respect
the honor and courage and having an
anti-government position that says why
should I
have to defend my country physically or
why should I have to spend my money
defending my country from a military
attack or a hurricane or a financial
crisis but that's what nation states do
that's what it means to be a
nation-state is that you can scripture
young men to defend your territory and
you're going to confiscate your people's
wealth to defend yourself against a
financial crisis that's what every
nation state does if it doesn't do that
it's not a nation-state so it's an ant
so the whole Cyprus example
you know and it's preying on a kind of
ignorance of people because it makes it
sound like the Cyprus government was
just whatever as opposed to like no
actually there's a whole context there
of why the Cyprus government did that
um now in terms of the security of
Bitcoin I mean I find the other thing as
a newcomer to the space sort of shocked
that that whole rap that you just gave
never mentions the fact that that dude
lost 127 million dollars of Bitcoin
because he left it in his car
Bitcoin is as secure as gold no but but
that's like saying um I always think of
the security of an asset as the further
away from the spigot the less secure it
becomes so I'll use dollars as an
example don't use Bitcoin uh the dollars
to answer the Cyprus example while
you're at it yeah so so the dollars that
are created you know treasury Federal
Reserve like the treasury's never been
uh infiltrated hacked uh robbed anything
like that now when the dollars leave and
they go in a physical truck and they're
driven somewhere there's plenty of
armored trucks that have been uh robbed
when it sits in a bank there's plenty of
banks that have been robbed right and
then if you have the dollars in your uh
wallet or your pocket you walk down the
street and someone you know hits you
over the head with a wrench they take
the money from you as well so the
further you get away from kind of the
creation point of uh the currency the
less secure it becomes that's dollars
with Bitcoin same thing the Bitcoin
blockchain where the actual Bitcoin uh
is
um held in terms of this public Ledger
uh that is not ever been hacked before
now if you go and you put your Bitcoin
on a physical Hardware wallet and then
you leave the hardware wallet on the
counter at McDonald's right or you leave
it in your car and someone robs your car
then yes of course but that's the same
thing as if you left the five dollars
you know sitting in your cup holder and
you left your car unlocked right so the
further you get on that let me Anthony
let me pause on that okay because if I
if I lose my CR because of course the
big case for Bitcoin and other you know
digital assets is that they are more
secure for example than having your
money in a bank but the only example
that you have is Cyprus and I'll let you
get to that because I interrupted but
the other example is the credit card
well I mean if I leave my credit card at
the supermarket or at the airport and of
course I've done that many times as most
of us have
um and somebody picks it up this has
actually never happened but if somebody
picks up and they start spending on it
the credit card company will actually at
this point I believe they do not hold me
accountable for it especially if I call
right away and I'm like I lost my credit
card they're like they put an end to it
whatever that's a much more secure
digital asset so so so in that case
given that like a credit card versus a
hard drive with Bitcoin or some other
um digital asset on it clearly the
credit card is more secure but but then
you're left with snipers but but it's
not because the credit the credit card's
not an asset right the credit card is
you're spending someone else's money and
they're just saying you don't have to
pay us back but it's not actually more
secure whereas with Bitcoin bank account
yeah so with Bitcoin if let's say I put
on a hardware wallet and I leave it in
my car and you take the hardware wallet
you have the hardware wall but you don't
have my Bitcoin because you still need
the private key right and if I just have
the private key in my head then I still
own that Bitcoin unless you have the
private key you don't have the Bitcoin
right that might be that might be fine
but I think the point is is that like my
assets and my bank account are really
freaking secure they've been they're
more secure than Bitcoin they're more
secure than cash they're more secure
than gold like there's no there's no
real now my you know both of my parents
my both sits of my parents have been
scammed recently
um and it was like annoying but like
they didn't like lose like a significant
sum of money and when that happens
usually there's some sort of lawsuit or
some sort of reconciliation the bottom
line is that we have more secure our
assets are more secure than they've ever
been at a physical and Technical and and
and monetary level in human history so
Bitcoin doesn't neither Bitcoin nor any
digital asset system offers greater
security outside of some frankly
outlandish political scenario like
Cyprus which I want to give you a chance
to answer to begin which is even a case
where it's like just to turn it all back
on you know like if you if if Bitcoin
were actually really worth something the
Cyprus government would find a way to
take that too because that's what nation
states do they will just take your
assets
um if they need them to defend the
nation-state so I mean that's I that let
me so we can pause and let you answer
the Cypress question so so
um during the 2008 2009 Global financial
crisis did any banks go bankrupt
yes right if your bank went bankrupt and
you had more than 250 000 in an account
there's no insurance
and people lost money
and so they put their money into an FDIC
insured bank account and even though it
was FDIC insured they still the bank
failure ended up losing the money so yes
on the wait wait I don't know I'm not
I'm not even sure I'm understanding like
if you had your money in an FDIC insured
account during the 2008-2009 financial
crisis you did not lose your money no
that's not true if you have more than
250 000 in one account you lost in in
the bank went bankrupt they only the
FDIC insurance only applies at 250 000
in the account so if you have three
hundred thousand that fifty thousand
dollar difference is not insured you
will lose that if your bank goes
bankrupt and who and how much was lost
okay well I'm being educated then so in
2008 2009
how many consumers lost how much money
from bank failures that's a great
question I don't know what that answer
is um but it'd be interesting to find
out and I think what we could probably
find out is uh 2008 like uh
um number of Bank bankruptcies we'll do
a little uh little Google uh slew thing
while we're going so there was 25 bank
failures in 2008 according to fdic.gov
uh and I'm sure each one of them frankly
has uh a whole bunch of different
details
um but when you look at the total assets
of those banks in
2008 um looking at a bank failures in
brief uh there was
373 billion dollars that were in those
banks that failed uh during
um of the bank failures in
2007-2008. so again that doesn't mean
that everyone lost all the money if all
373 uh billion dollars was in FDIC sure
to council less than 250 Grand then
would have all been protected so I don't
know what the number or difference is
but the point is that in 2008 there was
25 bank failures in 2009 there was 140
bank failures and in 2010 there's 157
bank failures in the United States
and so yeah but don't yeah go ahead I
was gonna say I think that there's
probably a power law right JP Morgan has
you know way more Assets in them than
obviously some small bank and and you
can imagine credit unions and kind of
all these smaller organizations but I
think it goes back to this uh Cyprus uh
example which is
um you know if you have more than 250
000 in an account and FDIC isn't
covering uh the additional amount uh to
some degree you made a mistake right
it's your fault whether you think you
made the mistake or not there's a
personal responsibility you took your
money you put it into a bank you thought
it was if the bank ended up not being
safe it's not your fault that the bank
failed but you made the decision to put
the money in and you chose an
organization that ended up ultimately
failing the government provides that 250
000 FDIC insurance is kind of a safety
net and you put more money in there than
uh kind of protected and so again
personal responsibility that's your
fault I think the example in Cyprus
which is you didn't choose an
organization that failed it's not the
banks that failed right it was actually
the government and they needed the
revenue and so they were skating now to
your point
um I I understand very much the pacifist
view I don't know if you know this I was
actually uh in the US Army I deployed
overseas there's a whole bunch of stuff
we could unpack in terms of uh people's
perspective on uh war and and all these
things and and many of the uh
misconceptions and probably we've seen
more eye to eye than you would think
um but in the United States we have a
voluntary military force and I actually
think that if there was some massive
Financial Calamity and we went out to
the citizens and we said hey there is a
a billion dollar shortfall you use a
relatively small number for finance and
we need a billion dollars donated in
order to keep the U.S financial system
up I think a lot of people would say hey
you know what I'll throw them 20 bucks
right I'll throw in a hundred dollars
like I don't want bad things to happen
but when it becomes less about the
individual's choice just as it's a
volunteer military force or voluntary uh
kind of propping up of their own economy
and it becomes a we are going to use a
monopoly on violence and Power in order
to confiscate your wealth and in the
United States what would be a violation
of the U.S Constitution that's where I
think people say oh hold on a second
here why would we ever put ourselves in
a position to allow people to do that
and the one last thing I'll say on this
and then I'd love for you to respond is
I actually agree with you this is like a
point zero zero zero zero one percent
chance of happening in the United States
like the United States in my opinion is
the greatest country in the world uh if
you could pick anywhere in the world
you'd want to live in the United States
we have Democratic uh political system
we've got a capitalistic Society we tend
to have the most free society when it
comes to a whole bunch of different
things around speech and all this so
it's not me predicting it happening I'm
just saying that Bitcoin affords certain
things when it comes to security uh and
the anti-confiscation or the
anti-censorship that other occurrencies
don't allow there's no other currency in
the world that would allow you to hold
it and if for whatever reason someone
wanted to confiscate it allow you to not
let them do that
yeah well so just to finish the Cypress
issue I mean so I mean my point is much
simpler which is that if the United
States or Cyprus were being invaded
um it wouldn't be a voluntary uh
military force to repel the Invaders
similarly when you're under a financial
crisis which is what they were under
um or if we were of course the
government would seize people's assets
like that's what happens
um and you can like kind of go well
that's not fair or whatever but like you
live in a nation-state the government is
not like another corporation like the
government is responsible for like
protecting us from external harm that's
Hobbes
um and like there's a sort of sense I
get from when I hear people talk about
this that kind of goes well what right
does the Cyprus government have to take
my money in a financial crisis it's like
you are a citizen of the nation-state of
Cyprus and when they're having a
financial crisis they're going to use
the assets they have available to
protect their nation state they're not
going to become a ward of
whatever they're not going to be invaded
by another country and they're not going
to let their currency collapse so but
Cyprus was hired Cyprus was hired by the
citizens
right the the in the United States I as
a citizen I am paying for the government
I'm paying for the local government I'm
paying for the state government I'm
paying for the national government
hiring is not the correct word well of
course it is because I hired the state
of North of New York no right because
hiring is optional hiring is something
that an employer of a I mean hiring like
you're paying your taxes well that's not
the same thing as being as hiring
somebody but here's a good way and I
think maybe this is a difference of
perspective I hired the state of New
York when I lived there and they
provided me services and when I chose
that I didn't think I was getting my
money's worth I voluntarily hired a
different state government and I moved
to Florida
right you're just I mean you're just
using like inappropriate language from
the private sector to describe
um your obligations to the nation state
but but because they're not the same but
see this is a difference my obligations
to the nation state is the government is
here to represent the people the people
are not here to serve the government
there are hundreds of thousands of
people who fired California and New York
in the last 24 months and they hired
Texas and Florida
to the point where they literally lost
political seats because people said I am
paying money and the services that I am
getting do not fulfill what my needs or
desires are and so I think this is like
one of the big things here is it's
personal choice like you can vote with
your dollars and you can vote with your
feet and what we saw over the last 24
months is usually just domestically I
don't think actually there was one talk
track of people are gonna like uh uh
repeal their citizenship they were going
to move to some crazy country somewhere
around the world I actually don't buy
that I don't think people are going to
do that I think the U.S passport and U.S
citizenship is uh kind of the light on
The Shining Hill right everyone wants to
become a U.S citizen uh for the most
part yes there are some people who say
no but there's a lot of people who want
to become U.S citizens
but I 100 think that
if a government is not fulfilling the
needs and wants and desires of citizens
they will move they will take their
dollars elsewhere and they will fire
right again when we go to The Ballot Box
if you're an incumbent and you don't get
reelected you got fired by the people
yeah but you're misdescribed you're
using an appropriate language from the
world of capitalism to describe the
relationship between citizens and their
government but we have a capitalistic
Society reason why we don't mix those
two languages because it's inaccurate
and misleading
um if you are a if you want to live
somewhere
um you're almost certainly going to pay
taxes and it's not optional whereas it
is optional about whether you hire
somebody and you can just use you're
just using confusing language when you
describe the process of electing new
governments throwing out old politicians
but isn't that hiring and fine language
but aren't we hiring new politicians and
firing old politicians like they have a
job I mean I mean I think the fact that
you want to kind of die on that hill of
using inappropriate
um Market language to describe
um politics and democracy and governance
um doesn't help your case because it
actually it suggests that there's a kind
of Hardcore libertarianism there look
man I mean if we go to war with China I
don't care where the [ __ ] you're gonna
move to in the world like the US
government is going to find some way to
like if you have some ability to serve
in that war they're going to grab your
ass and make you fight for America and
similarly that's going to include
grabbing all your Bitcoin and being
that's just what it would be to be at
War and you know that as well as anybody
because you served in the military but I
think that like there's this idea that
like oh God you know the Cyprus
government they took their people's
money and what right do they have well
the right they have is that they're the
government it's the nation-state and yes
if they don't respond to what the people
want then that nation state that
government will either be overthrown
democratically or through violence or
some other means but that's politics
that's not consumerism Bitcoin is trying
to sort of and this is metaphorical here
I mean it's sort of introducing
inappropriately a kind of political
agenda and passing it off as a kind of
digital Revolution
it's not what it is you know it's um you
know there's a lot of Beauty in the
Bitcoin in the initial Bitcoin paper
there's something really artistic and
interesting about it and then certainly
blockchain technology is super
interesting and I don't know anybody
that wants to get rid of it but the
claim that this is some alternative
currency to like the dollar or the Euro
or the yen is just wrong it's literally
um false advertising and even the word
cryptocurrency is false advertising and
the reason for that is that you are a
citizen of the United States and if you
want to go and renounce your citizenship
and go and be an Israeli or a European
or a Brazilian or whatever yeah you can
do that but then you're going to have
obligations to that nation state and
there is no sea studying and the reason
is is that that's just being a pirate
yeah
I don't think that anyone in the well
maybe not anyone but I don't think the
majority of the Bitcoin Community thinks
that there's no obligations right in
fact what I think we're seeing is that
politicians around the country sure I've
spent a bunch of time with many of them
both at the local state and federal
level they're competing to get
bitcoiners to move to their areas and to
their uh kind of ecosystems because
there's more tax revenue right this is
one of the fastest growing sectors of
the economy both in terms of job
creation in terms of economics and then
obviously from taxation as well and so
that's why you see States like Texas you
see States like Kentucky Florida Ohio
Etc all competing to try to get these
people to move there but I think because
they compete for Herbalife conferences
too yeah but but of course not on the
same size nor scale as to what we're
seeing from these politicians and real
estate agents like to sell to drug
dealers I mean so what but if they want
to sell it but if they want to sell to
drug dealers right the the U.S banks
wander more money than the Bitcoin
ecosystem right so let's make it harder
than not easier I mean well Bitcoin does
make it harder the whole Bitcoin thing
is doomed because honestly you're gonna
to have guys like me who are going to
fight on on the right and the left to in
especially as [ __ ] goes sideways in
terms of the economy that are going to
fight to not allow Bitcoin to move from
the black market economy into the
mainstream economy that's why I don't
want to see it regulated it's not it's
actually not a thing all we should do is
warn consumers to stay the hell away
from it it is part of a radical
political agenda that the vast majority
of people are not on board with because
we actually prefer to have functioning
nation states that have that's not true
the days that protect us the White House
disagrees that we can defend it and so
the White House disagrees though 14 of
U.S citizens according to the White
House own this asset yeah because they
don't understand what it is because
they've been scammed I mean people buy
Herbalife and they buy but not 14 by
Bernie Madoff not 14 CF was the SPF is
the face of crypto not not 14 not 14 of
the U US population
owns the asset
150 plus million people around the world
does more transaction volume than
MasterCard
in a given year the biggest it's a huge
financial scam and it's crashing what's
the scam this actually this would be
interesting to talk about uh there's no
use value but well okay so hold on so if
you were an accidental activity if you
were to ask me what is the use cases for
Bitcoin right I would argue there's a
store value just buy it and hold it for
a long period of time the second in no
different than gold a house uh I could
literally say that do things with gold
gold you can do things with gold has a
lot of purposes well no but I'm just
saying that there's store value I could
it may be a bad store value but I could
go outside I could buy a bunch of rocks
from somebody who's a rock dealer and
just hold them in my house and say I
think that in the future it's gonna be
worth more money so store value is so
valuable than your Bitcoin for sure
those rods okay so hold on so store
value the second thing is medium of
exchange the nice thing is that uh
rather than debate no value then this
exchange is pointless but I would argue
that uh you think let's say for example
why why run away from the use question
let's talk about that somewhere well
because I'm walking through it if you
can scan people into paying money for it
but see here's the way it's useful
otherwise it has no benefits in terms of
digital transactions zero benefits so
you're saying that 14 percent so
according to your uh kind of uh thought
process here 14 of the US uh population
has been scammed these are consenting
these are consenting free individuals
who come together my family
you're saying your wife was scammed yes
I am all right so in all seriousness you
have store value you have medium of
exchange the third thing which we talked
about earlier is speculation I actually
think that is a use case no different
than a bunch of others there's no if
there's no use to the if it's if it's
completely just
funny money like Herbalife at the end of
the day or in tupperware my mom was
Tupperware you know pyramid schema it
was great we ended up with tupperware at
the end of it or you end up with a bunch
of Herbalife yeah it's more Herbalife
than you need for yourself but who cares
do you have some Herbalife with Bitcoin
you have nothing I mean at worst and and
even worse than that though you've
basically legitimized and normalized
money laundering so that it's easier if
you were to make Bitcoin successful be
easier to get drug money to be able to
buy that no it's harder it's harder like
if you go talk to I've talked to an FBI
uh doj any of these folks you go talk to
them they would prefer people use
Bitcoin over any other currency in the
world because it is easier to track what
criminal wants to conduct criminal
transactions on a public Ledger that is
immutable it never can be changed and
people can go back and look all the way
from the beginning every single
transaction that was done that's how all
these guys are getting caught is because
they're using I mean I mean there's just
bill billions and billions I mean just
just people can Google crypto billions
stolen crime and you just end up with
too many news articles then you can read
but hacks I mean hacks are different
than money laundering the former CIA
director did a study and he estimated
that point O or I'm sorry 0.4 less than
half a percent of all transactions on
the Bitcoin blockchain have anything to
do with nefarious purposes so not just
money laundering any nefarious purpose
point four percent compared to they
estimate two trillion dollars a year in
Fiat currencies
and so when you call yeah because yeah
but that's not relative
why is it not relative
well you're because there's a lot more
fiat currency okay but how how much more
fiat currency 80 there's 80 trillion
dollars I mean Anthony there's no
there is no utility to this thing okay
would you would you argue that there is
utility if you buy your house and you
live in it there's utility from living
in it but also a use case of buying your
house is the belief that it's going to
go up in value so if I buy Bitcoin and I
just you can't then go get rid of the
house part of that story and then go
well because it's also a speculative
asset of course ideas that are only
speculative assets tulips had value
Herbalife has value Tupperware has value
pyramid schemes even Madoff I think that
they ended up people ended up getting
back like 80 of you know their money
crypto ultimately should be zero like if
people were rational it would have like
zero value except for maybe some value
as like an art project but it would
really have zero value so so just so I'm
clear you think that uh anti-censorship
anti-cizorship private property rights
and expression in the digital realm of
free speech those have zero value
well like I said I would give it a
little bit of of value like as a burning
man project all right so we're not at
zero so we've got some value like one of
those things like the burning man it's
like a kind of like display of kind of
digital interestingness and but it's
also very wasteful in terms of I mean
I'm not opposed to energy consumption
um but I just don't think it just
doesn't it's not it's just I look I just
don't think I think in general you just
don't there's no point to it so it's
like it's like you can talk about all
these other benefits like the
speculative value or the or the exchange
value but if you don't have if it's not
a thing
when you know if it's just a bunch of
[ __ ]
um and it's or it's an art project then
it should be valued at an art project
value not at anything beyond that how do
you respond to the fact that the the
that Bitcoin has been the only
disciplined independent Central Bank
over the last three years during all
this chaos and uncertainty
um it's it's not a central bank
why not you might want it to be why is
it not that's a fantasy but that's not
what it is a central bank is the Fed or
the European Central Bank well those are
human human-led central banks that have
two activities right no it's just that's
just that's just word salad that you're
using in the same way that people say
cryptocurrency when it's not a currency
well currency is anything that people
transact for goods or services right
nope no what is a currency I mean it's
not a national currency the national
currency is different than a currency
yeah I mean
um I think that the point is that it's
it's meant to mislead like bad language
take the central banks here's the things
that are meant to mislead the word
currency the word Central Bank in
reference to digital assets Cyprus
um claims that there's more fiat
currency uh crime than uh than uh than
crypto uh uh digital asset crime these
are all things meant to distract people
from the fact that there's no there
there that there's no there's no product
of value here it's just a kind of
fantasy it's a post-modernist media
driven
pyramid scheme on top of a criminal
Enterprise on top of an art project
slash nothing Burger you know and I look
I mean this is why it's good to talk and
unfortunately I have to go back to
working on this article I'm working on
but I mean
um the great thing about free of speech
and we great we agree on all these
things I can tell you that your product
is worthless I mean that's the best part
of it yes and you can disagree
but I also can in free speech is I can
fight for your right to say that 100
like we we are fully on your rights and
I'll fight for your right to sell you
know
nonsense
no it I I think that um I I don't think
that we are going to come to a
uh eye to eye in terms of what bitcoin's
value is the one thing that I would say
is
um your view of the world in terms of
many of the things that you've described
today I actually think align much more
with the bitcoiner view of the world
than you may realize uh and no I have
many
like I said family and friends yeah it's
like probably one of the smartest people
I've ever met
it's not a um
you know
um he's just trapped in a really bad
idea
um and and ideas are really powerful I
mean people get trapped in all sorts of
bad ideas I've been trapped in bad ideas
I've just been working my way out of
them by writing two books about those
bad ideas but ideologies are powerful
um
but reality is more powerful
I think that's a great place to leave it
Michael thank you so much for taking the
time to do this appreciate you brother I
really enjoyed it and hopefully we'll
meet in person at some point